in this video we shall take a detailed
look into one of the most deadliest
kaiju ever
the arch nemesis of godzilla which is
destroyer
and also known as destroyer and also
known as the sarizawa legacy
it is a kaiju created by the oxygen
destroyer in 1954
when it was used to try and kill
godzilla which it succeeded
but only to also mutate a prehistoric
crustacean that survived for millions of
years
and avoided many mass extinction events
seen in the 1995 film godzilla vs
destoroyah
this is a kaiju that transforms into
many different forms on the battlefield
in all these forms destroyer possesses a
crustacean exoskeleton
with various tones of red just a quick
info about this dreaded kaiju
destoroya grows quickly and adopts
several appearances
throughout the film his design has also
been influenced by
another movie monster which is one of
the most famous and beloved as well
as fear it has some of the same features
as the aliens from the alien franchise
such as the inner jaw so in this video
we will discuss
all its five forms and also justify why
this fan favorite
should be in the monsterverse he was the
embodiment of transformation
and some would say evolution as well as
the same as
shin godzilla this kaju was supposedly
planned to appear as the final villain
again
in final wars but was replaced by
monster x
so before we go into the five forms of
destroyer let's see how it came into
being
destroyed originated as a colony of
microscopic crustaceans
from the pre-cambrian era that had
thrived living in anaerobic environments
when the oxygen destroyer was detonated
to kill the first godzilla in 1954
these crustaceans were mutated from
exposure to the chemical weapon
and began to evolve abnormally over the
next 40 years
incorporating microoxygen into their
biological processes
later after being disturbed by
underwater mining they began feeding on
organic life and combined with each
other into larger and more deadly forms
so let's see how it evolved and took on
the different forms
the first form in this first form
destroyer resembles a tiny trilobite
with a flattened shell and multiple
spiked protrusions
emerging from its shell which vaguely
resembles its later forms
headquests this form is about a
centimeter long
and was first observed consuming fish in
an aquarium micro destroyer keeps on
growing so it started as one millimeter
tall
three meter meters long and weighs 0.5
kilograms
well it was actually growing gradually
but retained the same form until it was
the size of an insect
later in this form it began to look more
like a tiny horseshoe crab
that was red in color and this all
happened when the tiny forms fed on
organic matter
and grew in number and size the second
form
in this second form the chinese insect
destroyers
combine to form a larger version which
was 2 meters in height
and would actually grow into about 18
meters tall in the same form
in this juvenile form destroyer looks
like a giant spider-like crab creature
with a frill on its head
and a secondary mouth inside its mouth
the inner jaw
it gains the ability to fire a
micro-oxygen beam in this form
and this form already spots a horned
crested head similar to that of the
final form
but its mouth is insect-like with
multiple sets of mandibles
there were many of these juvenile
destroyers and quite a number were
killed by using flamethrowers
and was sent to hiding later on the
third form
these juvenile forms which were hiding
would eventually come out together to
form an aggregate form
but before this happened the
self-defense forces deployed mazer tanks
armed with ultra low temperature lasers
and tanks with cadmium shells
they opened fire on the juvenile
destroyers when they resurfaced and
destroyed many of them
but they did eventually manage to
combine together and this destroyer
looks
like a much larger version of the
juvenile but with two
crab claws and two massive spear-like
claws on his back
this aggregate destroyer is 60 meters
tall 40 meters long and weighs
15 000 tons and by this time the
self-defense forces could not match its
power
the fourth form in this form destroyer
finally battled godzilla
well junior godzilla actually right
after combining into its aggregate form
some time later it evolved wings which
gave it the ability of flight
in this flying form destroyer has two
wing-like lobes on its sides
a forked tail and a nasal horn it gains
flight capabilities and retains its
micro-oxygen beam
flying destroyer is 65 meters long with
a wingspan of 80 meters
and weighs 15 000 tons this form battled
with godzilla junior until it was shut
down by an atomic breath
and reconstituted itself back into the
third form or the aggregate form
it then again battled with junior until
it was sent into its presumed
destruction ending the fight temporarily
the fifth form re-emerging from the
burning refinery
its final form is the largest one of all
this form sports bat-like wings
large curved horns on the sides of its
head a humanoid body structure
and a long tail with a pincer at the end
this forms face is more dinosaurian with
a white mouth filled with
sharp teeth and overall resembles a
traditional depiction of a demon
perfect destroyer as it is known as 120
meters tall
and 230 meters long with a wingspan of
210 meters
and weighs 80 000 tons it has
thick arms and legs adorning the white
claws
the knee area of the legs has white
spikes protruding out
the flower like structure on the chest
is red white and on the shoulders
there are large red white spikes finally
there is a long
orange horn that projects from the top
of the head
so now that we have discussed all the
five forms of destroyer
what about the powers that desaroya has
in its perfect form
well it retains its primary weapon the
microoxygen beam
and it can use this to disintegrate any
life-form it comes in contact with
and feed on the organic matter
destoroyah can also shoot a concentrated
beam of microoxygen from its mouth
that suffocates and eats away all other
life forms
aside from that destroys horn can also
extend into a long powerful laser
that slices effortlessly through
godzilla's indestructible
flesh it was also planned to have
another beam attack which was called the
oxygen destroyer cannon
whereby it shields a beam from its chest
pattern composed of pure oxygen
and which would have been its ultimate
attack also it can also regenerate
or break down into smaller forms
reproduce again
and heal and then recombine to form
either its aggregate forms or its final
demonic form
now that we've discussed about the
powers
what about its weaknesses its primary
weakness is extreme temperature
both the extreme heat and coal this is
because destroy's body contains a large
amount of micro
oxygen and this element can be liquefied
or completely vaporized at high
or low temperatures another one of its
weaknesses is the chest cavity
and so by blasting destroyer in its
chest cavity with his atomic breath
godzilla ruptured destroys insides and
made it vomit out blood from its mouth
after being punched in its wounded chest
destroyer had to disassemble itself
and recombine later to avoid dying from
the fatal injury
and so it wasn't as indestructible as
previously thought
and could be very well be easily killed
by a nuclear bomb owing to the extreme
heat a nuke would generate so what do
you guys
think should destroy be included in the
monster verse i mean godzilla has
already fought
against two enemies at once then for an
ancient rival
in the muto prime in the comics in the
second film he fought his own nemesis
ghidorah
and gained the loyalty of rodan and the
other titans and next year he will be
facing kong in an epic duel that might
include mechagodzilla as well
therefore if there was another monster
was filmed then destroyed would be
perfect as the final villain ending both
godzilla and itself
as in the 1995 film so do subscribe for
more
monster videos we've come to the end of
this video and do check out some of
those that you might have missed
by going to our channel anyway do click
that bell button as well
for regular updates